monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre de l'Économie ma question
s'adresse à vous parce que
l'Île-de-France veut redevenir ce
qu'elle était dans le passé c'est-à-dire
le moteur de la croissance de notre pays
le projet qui avait été lancé par
Nicolas Sarkozy du Grand Paris était un
projet qui à la fois devait améliorer
les transports et la vie quotidienne des
Franciliens mais aussi recréer cette
dynamique les arbitrages de la semaine
dernière du Premier ministre sont connus
sur les tracés il peut y avoir des bas
mais globalement tout le monde est
d'accord en revanche monsieur le
ministre il y a des réserves les miennes
mais celle de beaucoup sur à la fois le
phasage jusqu'en 2030 au-delà et sur le
fait que curieusement les pôles de
développement essentiel Roissy Orly la
défense sont dans la dernière phase or
voilà un Grand Paris Express qui coûte
26 milliards sur lequel je le dis tout
de suite pour assurer le président
Gaudin l'état dit éventuellement nous
mettrons un milliard s'il y a besoin
ce qui veut dire qu'en réalité
l'essentiel pour ne pas dire la totalité
de la dépense elle est assurée par les
collectivités franciliennes par les
Franciliens par les entreprises non mais
je veux dire par là il y a pas de
demande de la part des Franciliens
envers l'État et c'est bien comme ça en
revanche monsieur le ministre
l'Île-de-France c'est 19% de la
population c'est 30% de la recette
fiscale le projet du Grand Paris c'est
150000 emplois c'est un point de
croissance c'est 50 milliards de
ressources fiscales supplémentaires pour
l'État dans les trottes dans les 30
années qui viennent 50 milliards de
ressources fiscales supplémentaires dont
mes chers collègues une partie très
naturellement ne revient pas sur
l'Île-de-France mais comme toujours dans
la dépense puisque sur les 30% de
recettes fiscales de l'Île-de-France 22%
sont reconsacrés par l'État
l'Île-de-France le reste c'est bien
normal sur une péréquation d'État
indépendamment des péréquations
législatives qui existent ça veut dire
quoi Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie
ça veut dire que que nous avons le
sentiment que le fait de pouvoir
réaliser ce projet que le fait de mettre
en avant les grands pôles de
développement très vite que le fait de
faire en sorte que les travaux démarrent
rapidement cette un élément de
croissance de création d'emploi et
d'enrichissement pour l'État et par
conséquent pour l'ensemble du pays et
nous vous demandons d'intervenir vous en
tant que ministre de l'économie avec
l'aspect budgétaire et financier pour
dire attention
commençons ou activons les secteurs qui
par définition sont ceux qui peuvent
entraîner le mouvement le plus
rapidement faisons en sorte de créer la
dynamique lorsque le Premier ministre
dit après 2020 on est plus très sûr du
financement je vous dis seulement
attention faisons en sorte tous ensemble
de réussir ce Grand Paris et ce grand
projet national
merci la parole à Monsieur Pierre
Moscovici ministre l'économie et des
finances
monsieur le sénateur Roger caoutchi je
veux excuser ici le Premier ministre qui
vous le savez tous est en déplacement au
Canada et qui m'a demandé de pouvoir
répondre à votre question Premier
ministre à présenter mercredi 6 mars
l'ambition du gouvernement pour
l'Île-de-France et quand je l'ambition
du gouvernement vous adressez à moi
c'est bien l'ambition de tout le
gouvernement que le premier ministre a
porté vous avez eu raison de dire que le
défi du Grand Paris c'est un défi
francilien bien sûr mais c'est plus
largement un enjeu de développement
économique pour la France entière et
nous souhaitons comme vous et je pense
que c'est partagé surtout les banques
l'Île-de-France soit un pôle extrêmement
important le principal dans le
développement du pays en tant que mise
de l'Économie des Finances je sais
l'importance de Paris du Grand Paris
dans le développement économique de
notre pays le projet du gouvernement il
incarne une politique de développement
un modèle de développement une politique
d'investissement que nous défendons
c'est un modèle de croissance bien sûr
mais qui l'oublie ni la solidarité entre
les Franciliens ni le désenclamment des
territoires un modèle de croissance ou
la mobilité va de pair avec un effort
pour le logement des Français et pour
leur cadre de vie le Premier ministre en
particulier présenté les décisions du
volant pour le schéma des transports du
nouveau Grand Paris qui articule la
rénovation du réseau existant et la
création de nouvelles lignes dans un
schéma global sans distinction entre ce
qu'il a été d'usage d'appeler le plan de
mobilisation d'autre part et le Grand
Paris Express d'autre part je vous le
rappeler ici d'ici à 2030 l'ensemble du
réseau du Grand Paris Express sera
réalisé les lignes étant lancées en
parallèle et faisons l'objet d'une
réalisation continue et c'est un
chantier très important vous appeliez à
cela vous serez satisfait au-delà
puisque les capacités d'ingénierie des
bureaux d'études l'outil industriel des
entreprises des travaux publics seront
mobilisés pour plus de 5 ans et
concrètement d'ici à 2017 il y a deux
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qui
seront affectés à la modernisation des
lignes existantes qui permettront de
porter les engagements possibles à 7
milliards d'euros c'est un effort sans
précédent bien sûr des discussions
seront poursuivies qui permettra aux
Franciliens de disposer de transport de
qualité au quotidien et cela sans
attendre conforteront l'attractivité de
la région Île-de-France pour les
entreprises la recherche universitaire
et privée donc la qualité de vie et
l'ensemble des pôles de la région
Île-de-France je peux vous l'assurer
seront pris en compte pour que tout ceci
se réalise il faudra une réforme
institutionnelle particulièrement en
matière de logement et d'aménagement et
vous savez que le gouvernement propose
une intercommunalité renforcée en
Île-de-France la création de la
métropole de Paris ainsi que les
pouvoirs renforcés à l'échelle régionale
pour garantir davantage de justice et
d'équilibre dans nos politiques
d'habitat je voulais donc vous rassurer
monsieur le sénateur il y a là un choix
ambitieux qui a été fait pour le
gouvernement qui est à la hauteur de
l'enjeu il appartiendra au Parlement de
sans saisir mais vous pouvez faire
confiance à la volonté du gouvernement
et à celle du Premier ministre personne
al